hello everyone my name is bradley and i
love traveling right and you know if
there's one rule that i've learned over
the years about surviving in a foreign
country is that you should always have
cash on you now i'm talking about this
because once in the netherlands i
actually tried to buy a painting i liked
in a small gallery
not only could i not buy it but i also
found myself eventually in a foreign
country without any money whatsoever why
well my card was actually blocked by the
bank on suspicion of money laundering
now of course i've already spoken to you
many times about how real criminals do
this in the real world but today i'm
going to take a closer look at how banks
fight against these scammers who do you
think blocked my card was it human or
artificial intelligence maybe i was the
first victim of a real machine uprising
now criminals launder probably about a
trillion dollars every single year and
if they did it the old-fashioned way
through laundries or washes right they
would need one in six of all printed
dollars to transport all this wealth to
a secret vault you'd have to load 2500
trucks with hundred dollar bills
that's why these days money laundering
occurs not through cash transactions in
the united states alone financial
organizations actually spent more than
seven billion dollars
annually to combat this it's the same
amount of money as investors have
invested in spacex over the years from
the moment of its conception through to
the launch of the first crew to the iss
not even gravity contains humanity when
we explore as one for all
of course this makes more sense if we're
talking about rockets right but what is
this much money actually spent on in the
financial system just a couple of years
ago the main tool for combating money
laundering was manual verification of
all banking transactions every day
analysts of american banks had to check
up to 800 000 transactions it's not
surprising that many programs have
appeared on the market that help to
identify such suspicious transactions
but now you know the industry is
undergoing some serious revolutionary
changes according to the association of
certified anti-money laundering
specialists more than half of all banks
worldwide are already engaged in the
implementation of artificial
intelligence in their aml processes
now let's figure out what artificial
intelligence is really capable of and
whether or not it can actually defeat
the human intelligence of scammers so
the very concept of anti-money
laundering or aml for short entered
banking practice in 1989. now the group
for the development of financial
measures to combat money laundering fatf
the financial election task force
proposed the first international aml
standards
also the ways to implement them and also
methods to combat the financing of
terrorism
let's imagine that i am working as an
amn analyst in a bank that say doesn't
use an artificial intelligence system
well what do i have to do of course i
don't have to manually review each
transfer the initial selection is done
by a computer algorithm that basically
looks for signs of suspicious behavior
and transactions now the algorithm also
pays attention to attempts to interact
with countries or spheres of business
that are recognized as high risk for
more advanced systems a history of
transactions is actually kept for each
payer and transactions also that are not
typical of previous activities are
submitted to manual review this all
sounds quite impressive but in fact it's
a set of very simple rules transferring
money to russia or iran is a suspicious
operation a red flag the transfer of a
million dollars by a phone that usually
operates in tens of thousands is a red
flag as is say the purchase of chemical
fertilizers by an i.t company now a set
of thousands of such rules is a fairly
reliable filter but the final decision
always lies with a person but let's
return to our automated systems do you
know what their work actually reminds me
of
chess computers
[Music]
now chess is obviously very difficult
but extremely logical game the pieces
the initial locations and possible moves
well these are all strictly regulated by
the rules of the game and they don't
change throughout
the number of combinations is huge here
and it also grows with every move
that is dirty
that is awesome
really awesome
[Music]
my team and i have launched a second
channel some sub for experts and if on
this channel for the past year i've told
you about how to protect yourself and
your data in the wild online jungle then
the second channel is for those who are
already professionals in their field for
those who are interested in biometric
user identification technologies as well
as those who would like to learn more
about kyc kyb aml and also countering
online fraud we hope that this channel
will form a great community of
professionals with whom we can share our
experience in use cases discuss new
fintech technologies and changes in
legislation this channel is hosted by my
colleague tony he's the chief legal
officer at some sub and also my good
friend in our next video tony will
interview experts from cyprus now he
will explain why cyprus is becoming such
a popular location for crypto businesses
and also what makes it different from
estonia lithuania and other very popular
jurisdictions in the near future we will
talk about open banking about corporate
registries as well as self-sovereign
identity solutions
in 1950 the american mathematician
claude shannon calculated that in chess
there's a possibility of 10 to the power
of 120 unique games now it's impossible
to calculate such a figure with outright
numeration but then how did a computer
beat a human at chess now the computer
algorithm does not iterate through all
possible combinations here on each one
it filters out the extra moves in fact
such algorithms actually cut off about
95 percent of obviously losing lines and
analyze the remaining ones now based on
this algorithm i suppose uh ibm actually
built the deep blue chess supercomputer
in 1997. it looked like two cabinets
into which they managed to actually cram
480 chess processors and 30 gigabytes of
ram and all of this allowed the
computers to calculate up to 330 million
positions per second at a match in new
york deep blue actually managed to beat
the strongest chess player in the world
gary kasparov but contrary to numerous
articles this was not a victory for
artificial intelligence the only thing
it could do although with incredible
speed was sort through the data
according to clearly defined rules
furthermore it didn't know how to learn
the algorithm of the game did not change
depending on the opponent's play or in
reaction to the moves that they make see
by definition intelligence natural or
artificial is the ability to perceive
information and retain it to adapt one's
behavior therefore the ibm chess a
thermometer is very similar to the
programs that many banks used just a few
years ago
aml analysis is much more complicated
than chess despite all of the
bureaucracy instructions laws and
regulations money laundering is a game
without rules criminals use non-standard
moves that go beyond the framework of
laws and patents and also finding
loopholes through which they can channel
money as quickly as possible they're
certainly not playing by the rules here
after all sometimes even financial
regulators of entire countries prefer to
turn a blind eye to such illegal
activities it's just easier have you
ever heard of moldova
it's a small agrarian country formerly
part of the ussr but gained its
independence in 1991. in the 20 years
since it has been chosen as the
metaphorical laundromat for all money
laundering activities by russian
oligarchs you can appreciate how
beautiful the scheme that they came up
with is
two offshore companies concluded a
fictitious loan
well for hundreds of millions of dollars
but of course in reality no money was
actually transferred to the borrower the
guarantors of the debt were russian
companies and citizens of moldova now
the borrower did not pay his debt and
the lender made demands on the
guarantors the case was examined by the
moldovan court and for this purpose
local guarantors were needed a corrupt
judge issued an official order obliging
the russian company to pay the debt the
company was happy to pay for this
non-existent transaction withdrawing
hundreds of millions of dollars to
offshore companies well during the
existence of such a scheme criminals
actually laundered 21 billion dollars
through moldova and also latvia now for
comparison the moldovan budget last year
was 10 times less than this figure at
only 2.4 billion did such sums really
not attract the attention of the
country's central bank well in order not
to attract the attention of aml
specialists according to the organized
crime and corruption reporting projects
money was transferred in small accounts
to 732 banks from 96 countries around
the world
automated systems didn't see any
violations of the rules here the
companies complied with legal court
decisions right and hence there was no
reason for the red flags to appear human
experts also ignored formally legitimate
transactions right the activities of the
moldovan laundromat were revealed only
thanks to the hard work of journalists
from a dozen different countries
moreover the reason for the
investigation was data leaks from
anonymous sources aml systems of the
previous generation are not designed
really to work with real-time payments
for each operation they must perform a
series of sequential checks when
analyzing a payment a few basic
conditions are checked first for example
they search the payer and recipient in
certain blacklists it is only the next
level that the activity of the client
and the change in the nature of the
regularity of payments can be analyzed
now there's a risk here of missing
several suspicious payments before the
client actually attracts any attention
now the use of standardized rules
significantly increased the risk of
false positives and that's exactly what
happened to my card the purchase of the
painting was regarded by the program as
a potential withdrawal of money now the
expert agreed with the program because
he didn't see any other payments from my
card in this region whatsoever the last
operation was actually performed just 12
hours prior in the vicinity of london
the email expert then introduced that my
data was stolen by scammers and blocked
it as a result according to experts it's
only about five in a hundred suspicious
transactions that are actually illegal
you need to remember also the burden on
enamel employees is growing in
proportion to the growth in the volume
of operations
stress increases as any suspended
transaction threatens to actually lose
or damage that client relationship so
you really have to work in a short time
frame here and this will also increase
the likelihood of human error
in addition a person is not able to keep
in mind all of the operations taking
place at the bank at best they can only
focus on their sector now if i really
worked as an aml analyst my job would
remind me of panning for gold it's often
necessary to sift through hundreds of
kilograms of water to find perhaps only
a few grains of gold but is it really
possible to identify these kinds of
schemes without informants and before a
couple of years have passed i'm talking
in real time and using only the data
that you've got your hands on and say
customer knowledge well the answer is
yes and for this you'll have to change
the traditional chess board for a goban
now this is the name of a playing field
for go
[Music]
for many years this ancient chinese game
remains to be the holy grail for
artificial intelligence developers go
has far fewer rules than chess or
chequers for that matter two players
effectively take turns laying out their
stones to create a territory that is
larger than that of their opponents and
that's basically the rules that it has
but computers learned to actually beat a
person
in this game of go only in 2015 18 years
later than in chess but why do you think
that is
well it's all about the number of
options here there are 361 possible
initial moves in go and 360 possible
responses now that's 129 960
combinations after the first round alone
even cutting off weak moves it's
impossible to solve such a task through
brute force measures
to win this game developers had to
change their approach alphago as
google's deepmind programmers called it
is based on neural networks now the way
it works is somewhat resemblance to that
of our brain
the creators didn't need to upload
complex algorithms for playing go to
alphago just the basic rules the size of
the field the order of moves and also
the scoring mechanism and then they
began to train the network step by step
by introducing parties of real players
the network identified patterns
successful and failed chains of moves
and also a general strategy of behavior
this is called the learning process with
a teacher and it's by this principle
that most neural networks are trained
however the disadvantage here is obvious
without a large training sample of data
nothing will work at all after we take
that first version that's learnt to
mimic human play we then allow it to
play itself 30 million times on our
servers and using reinforcement learning
um it the the system learns to improve
itself incrementally uh through uh
avoiding its errors but unlike deep blue
alphago didn't need any special
equipment so training could take place
in one of google's cloud services it
took the program four weeks to analyze
this data after that the network was
able to protect 57 of the moves of real
people but this wasn't really enough to
ensure a guaranteed victory right and
therefore programmers began to force the
network to play with itself each game
improved the algorithm network and soon
the effectiveness of the game increased
by a further 80 percent until in 2015
alphago won its first resounding victory
by beating three-time european champion
fan hui with a score of 5 and 0.
now it's a complicated thing
now six months later google's brainchild
defeated multiple world champion lee
sedol and two years later another
version of alphago zero appeared now its
name refers to the number of batches
that's used for training that's right
this neural network only knew the
general rules and learned by playing
with itself only now the duel between
the new version of alphago which
defeated lee sedol turned out to be a
triumph 4-0 it won with a score of 100
to 0.
the result kind of shocked the
professional community prior to the
launch of alphago experts estimated the
computer would learn to beat a person no
earlier than 2025 but the self-learning
neural network made a real breakthrough
in the use of artificial intelligence it
outperformed all previous versions of
alphago specifically
it defeated the version of alphago that
won against the world champion lee sidol
now do you see the difference between
alphago and ibm's chest computer well i
think i can it's clearly not a
calculator on steroids anymore but it
really can be called artificial
intelligence in a true form
according to human rivals google's
brainchild demonstrated an understanding
of the game and even surprised opponents
with non-standard moves that were never
seen before some of them have actually
already been
used and adopted by professional players
artificial intelligence which is able to
find hidden patterns and identify
patterns of player behavior attracted
the attention of developers of aml
systems
[Music]
artificial intelligence
moreover their work has increased
considerably coronavirus pandemic has
changed a lot in the world of e-commerce
and 2020 was remembered not only for the
colossal growth of internet payment
systems but also for the wave of hacking
of large companies that we experienced
for example the personal data of 400
million users was stolen from estee
lauder alone the list goes on but do you
know why such data is actually needed by
scammers
to breed mules money mules are people
who effectively receive illegally
obtained money into their accounts and
then they transfer it onwards this is a
classic scheme used by money launderers
around the world if we draw an analogy
with the computing world mules play the
role of proxy servers in practice it can
be very difficult to trace this kind of
chain of behavior and money effectively
disappears from sight prior to the
covert pandemic pre-existing accounts
were offensively used as mules sometimes
scammers gained access to them by
stealing passwords sometimes social
engineering methods came into play
people are actually persuaded to
transfer the accidentally transferred
amount to another account and some
customers actually made deliberate
payments for a small percentage in 2021
the situation changed dramatically in 90
of cases new bank customers became the
mules there are thriving trading
platforms in the darknet where you can
actually buy a full set of personal data
of a real person which scammers can then
use to open new bank accounts right now
it's becoming more profitable than ever
even for say payments of just a few
hundred dollars banks don't actually pay
much attention to transfers of such
amounts and the security services mainly
monitor attempts to take over old
accounts and thus
well the modern mule remains invisible
he opens an account using someone else's
documents and at first he looks like a
law-abiding citizen right he has not yet
formed a pattern of behavior now when it
becomes apparent this person is engaged
in holistic activity more than mule
already finished his work and moved on
the search for such anomalies is one of
the most striking abilities of the
neural network ai systems patterns in
small scale operations of mules are
fixed as clearly as the position of
stones on say a go board the system will
spot the new pattern even before aml
specialists find out about it and
describe it in the rules right
artificial intelligence systems are able
to change the perception of ml
specialists in relation to customer
segmentation they're usually divided by
country and city maybe industry and
business size and the result here is
logical clusters similar to industry
catalogs artificial intelligence is able
to divide customers into segments based
on their behavior now the standard
payments of any company are not going to
attract the attention of the system but
the behavior characteristic of already
identified fraudsters will be a glaring
red flag ai algorithms may not be
limited to banking information only they
can actually be trusted to collect
information from open sources so that
the aml analyst immediately has all of
the necessary information at hand to
make a decision do you remember the
story with my card in amsterdam well if
such a system was already working in the
bank the analyst would not have a single
question after he saw my selfie against
the background of the reiki museum at
least the guys from ibm claim that their
system reduces the number of false
positive warnings by 70
however os osint tools deserve a
separate conversation which we will
definitely return to in the future
[Music]
financial organizations are extremely
conservative in nature therefore
progress in the use of artificial
intelligence systems has been bypassed
by banks for a long time despite this it
is here in the pre-existing information
systems that there is something that
will allow ai to develop as efficiently
as possible i'm talking about structured
formalized and reliable data all reports
of suspicious payments internal reports
and detailed fatf recommendations are an
ideal set of training data for neural
networks every month american banks
conduct more and more transactions and
records about them are ideal material
for training neural networks we should
really be starting now with this stuff
and of course such systems will require
certainly a more complex infrastructure
the costs of building data centers will
increase the number of programmers and
say machine learning specialists will
also increase remember i said that more
than 50 banks are actually trying to
implement artificial intelligence
systems right now well the ubs evidence
lab report provides more detailed
information on this now at least 75
percent of banks with assets of more
than 100 billion dollars and just 46 of
banks with smaller assets use or are
still implementing ai-based tools
artificial intelligence is not a cheap
pleasure can you guess which banks will
now be paying more attention to
financial fraudsters and of course no
matter how well a computer plays chess
or go the final decision should always
be made by human amr specialists or are
you ready to trust artificial
intelligence anyway my name is bradley
and i hope you've enjoyed the video and
i will see you next time thanks for
joining us if a system like alphago can
learn all the moves in go well enough to
beat a person then it has the potential
to replace lawyers and accountants among
dozens of other jobs
[Music]
you